hey guys where games going 2014 I'm with
Daniel do iron ok we oh yeah hey Games
come we've just seen Assassin's Creed
unity but we played it we did I'm gonna
confess we both played it I was rubbish
so I'm gonna ask you about this me is so
bad tell me where I went wrong I'm
wondering equal to me play you were the
sacrificial lamb of the same because you
end it was a co-op demo we played one of
the producers and it was essentially
another sort of a and all the co-op
stuff is instanced within Assassin's
Creed there is an open-world game but if
you want to play with somebody got to a
quest giver and say I'll go play with a
dude and then it's just like localized
emission so this was a level where we
were going into the crypt of nacho DOM
deals and things deal some stuff and it
was a level saying how much stuff we
could steal and the more you got seen
the more that level went down and get
reward bar so basically trying to be hey
guys be stealthy and you can get better
bonuses for doing it's your reward bar
unfortunate I tried to cover this like
this stealth mechanics in that was a big
thing stealth mechanics are good while
you hold left trigger and you crunch
down and then you can push a to cover or
X whatever was your hover I remember and
I didn't do that very well evidently and
a bunch of dudes just like you I don't
like Black Flag where you could kill
every 50 people no problem if there's
like three you're in trouble yeah so the
two of you got swarms actually I quite
liked that because I always enjoyed the
combat and Assassin's Creed one the kids
he was all about carrying and then like
getting hit with a counter-attack and
this seems to be the same yeah and the
animations were roofs yeah it was a
quite enjoy whole thing look really good
as well yeah I had ago I had a little
bit more I'd seen what you were done I
learned from your mistakes
that's what exactly it's that's what
life's all about
and we went down to the Crypt very much
your you know stop the Assassin's Creed
fair there was some interesting stuff
like it kind of reminded me of the Dark
Knight Rises where a Catwoman is
intentionally seen so the guy walks
after and then shanked in the background
well he doesn't shank people but you did
well the guy did yeah they've also
brought is not the ghost mechanic from
splitter Cell Conviction yes well so you
get the last known position I always
really liked that so you know you know
if you're trying to break line-of-sight
you get that halo 4 where they think you
are or where they lost sight that's a
small farm and get a was fine it was it
was a real again sort of instance
compressed demo are you excited to play
unity after playing that I not after
necessarily playing vas mechanically
it's largely the game looks good
everything else I've seen it was you
know he likes to get hands-on finally it
definitely feels like starter screed but
like you were saying this stuff would be
the the mobs is definitely a step in the
right direction yes and stepping in a
backwards direction then we also got to
play Assassin's Creed rogue yes which is
the Xbox 360 Playstation 3 Assassin's
Creed game
which looked like an Xbox 360 game I can
see could say it did it looked like
black flag part 2 but if I can ways even
there via this new character this iris
did yeah and yeah you J Patrick she
actually Cormac yeah things right yes
three person a t-shape I asked them if
we're better our name is from somebody
interested apparently he's second
generation which may explain the
slightly funky accent yeah life's
hardest choices are the ones that force
you to question your own moral code yeah
but I was actually I liked what I saw in
that game I don't think anyone who
didn't like Black Flag will necessarily
like this but the boat combat stuff had
a lot of extra and new weapons name a
straight-up a sort of a machine gun
thing you can control yourself make the
lake of fire that you could put behind
like a veneer escaping oil slick think
oh cool and then probably the most
interesting part I found was that when
we were playing the when we're watching
and play the bass you know your
Assassin's Creed fair where you're
trying to kill one guy yeah they had a
lot more variation in terms of the the
rifle basically can shoot and shock on
the shells or great shells like made
launcher wasn't it yeah yeah but you can
shoot stuff like substance to make them
go asleep like the old art yeah or the
Berserker thing but neither thing is
like animals react to it so like Far Cry
4 3 you can shoot a dog and go eating
people there's also barrels of that
stuff around so there's a lot more
tactical killing and awareness and again
sort of like Splinter Cell oddly another
interesting part was that there because
you play as a Templar in the game and
Shay was originally an assassin and turn
Templar yeah there were like assassins
hiding in bushes yeah like just in the
map just like in the in the bushes
waiting for you and you get this like
you audio trigger whispers when you're
nearby so you can use your eagle vision
and you can spot them instantly with
eagle vision
that was good nice let me can I see you
got a glisten out for that stuff you're
not always see if your are gonna be it
was creepy yeah well he heard you were
like where's he gone where is he where
is he and then apparently if he actually
comes out and hurts you he takes off
quite a lot of damage and also you lose
your stealth as well yeah after that
tonight a nice addition but it
definitely looks and feels like a little
slight conversion you version two are an
expansion of Black Flag's exactly looks
like exact same kind of gameplay with
additional a little bit so if you like
lifelike then you'll probably like a
different part of the world as well as
sort of Pacific northeast apparently of
New York and a bunch of cities but yeah
yeah something for the current gen fans
I guess cuz they won't get in on you
today exactly well you know what get
Danny I enjoyed playing them I'm not
super excited but I want to see more but
if you guys let us know if you enjoyed
seeing the gameplay we've put up
listening to us talk about it stay with
Gainsborough of course for everything
else from games come on 2014
look at that guy